الآن في أوائل عام 2012 عندما فكرت فيسبوك في
الحصول على إنستغرام
شركة ناشئة تنافسية ، أخبرت رئيسك المالي
أنه على الرغم من أن إنستغرام الناشئ قد يكون
مزعجًا للغاية
لنا وفي الأسابيع التي تسبق الصفقة
التي وصفتها إنستغرام على أنها تهديد
للقول إن اقتباس
إنستغرام يمكن أن يؤذينا بشكل كبير
دون أن تصبح عملاً ضخمًا ، لا
تقتبس الآن السيد زوكربيرج ، ما الذي كنت
تقصده عندما وصفت instagram بأنه
تهديد
مزعج وعندما قلت إن
instagram يمكن أن
يضر الفيسبوك بشكل هادف ، هل
تقصد أنه
في المستهلك هل تقصد أن المستهلكين
قد ينتقلون من facebook إلى
شكراً لعضو الكونغرس في instagram على
الفرصة التي أتيحت لي لمعالجة هذا
في ذلك الوقت كان هناك مجال صغير ولكنه
متنام
أه هل قصدت أن
المستهلكين قد يتحولون من facebook
instagram وكان هذا سؤالي
شكرًا لعضو الكونغرس نعم أنت تعلم هل
قصدت ذلك
في  مساحة من صور الجوال
وتطبيقات الكاميرا
أه التي كانت تنمو أه
لقد كنت منافسًا  ProjectSyndicate ar لقد كنت واضحًا
بشأن ذلك
وكان جيدًا في فبراير من ذلك العام
في فبراير 2012 ، لقد أخبرت
المدير المالي لفيسبوك
أنك مهتم بشراء
instagram ، فسألك عما إذا كان
الغرض من الصفقة هو تحييد
منافس محتمل
أو الاندماج  منتجاتهم مع منتجاتنا
من أجل تحسين خدماتنا ،
أجبت أنه كان مزيجًا
من قول أن ما نشتريه حقًا
هو الوقت حتى لو كان بعض المنافسين الجدد
ينطلقون من أن هذه المنتجات
لن تحصل على الكثير من الجاذبية لأننا لدينا بالفعل
تم نشر آلياتهم على نطاق واسع
السيد زوكربيرج ، ما الذي قصدته عندما
أجبت بأن الغرض من الصفقة
هو تحييد منافس محتمل
أه عضو في الكونجرس هذه ليست
كلماتي ولكن
نعم لقد كنت واضحًا أن instagram كان
منافسًا
في  مساحة لمشاركة الصور على الهاتف المحمول ،
كان هناك الكثير من الآخرين في الوقت
الذي تنافسوا فيه مع تطبيقات مثل
viscocam
و pickplease وشركات مثل Path um كانت
مجموعة فرعية من  المساحة الإجمالية
للتواصل
التي نعيشها في أمم ومن خلال
جعلهم ينضمون إلينا أه بالتأكيد انتقلوا من
كونهم منافسين
في فضاء كوننا كاميرا محمولة
أه إلى
تطبيق يمكننا مساعدته في النمو والمساعدة في جذب
المزيد من الأشخاص ليكونوا قادرين  لاستخدامها
والانضمام إلى فريقنا وأعتقد أن هذا
كان ناجحًا للغاية